hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay I had
an idea about how I'm gonna get through
this and it's gonna be very very iffy
see I only have so many bullets even in
my machine gun I should have I should
have kept like either some Desert Eagle
rounds I should have saved him up or I
should have done something but I screwed
up and I don't have that but what I do
have is my immense skill at playing
video games and whatnot okay maybe I
don't have that either but what I do
have is a quick safe so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna bounce I think this is
the door that it opens because it looks
like there are three layers three layers
and there are three buttons behind that
curtain
that curtain and that curtain that's as
much as I have amassed now so what I'm
gonna do is once I hit one button I'm
going to quick save so that I can go
from there trying to get to the next
button and once I hit the next button
I'm going to quick save and fight my way
to the next button okay okay so let's
give this a try Oh No what's going on ah
and then they come out and they're gonna
say hi and then I'm gonna dodge them
just like a boss quick save up [ __ ] okay
dodge dodge dodge get another one
quicksave okay that's two down whoa
where'd you come from
friend Oh dodge dodge like a boss ah
quick yeah yeah yes yeah got it
mmm mother I didn't even need to oh I'm
so great mmm you're correct I didn't
even need to load
yes okay I don't know what that did but
whatever I can get up here yeah if they
come in here oh excuse me mm-hmm
scuse me if they come in here I can take
care of them actually let me do it this
way
save me some ammo don't see we be able
to get through this door oh this is
gonna take me a while to get through all
these get one down two down ah coming up
join me huh not today okay
one more there we go
three down quick save man holy crap
not today your tacks are slow and weak
oh yeah I am strong like prayer okay
actually let me just blow all right [ __ ]
did I save at a bad oh my god I did ha
ha ha oh that would have been terrible
okay I'm gonna try to get past some once
I can get cuz I didn't know regular save
I would have been totally bummed because
I would had to go all the way back ah
yeah what the hell yeah this one's a
toughy okay now let me reload here so
that I can try to make my way through
actually let me do a real
honest-to-goodness say because I don't
want to get caught up in the middle of
this [ __ ] ah yeah
can't touch this I think it opened what
where ah
okay cool alright making my way downtown
ba ba da ba ba da ba ba ba ba ba yeah
okay
OOP something in there ah pills yes ah
damn it no ah ah quick save after he hit
me are you kidding me Oh oh good there's
another quick save oh no there's not
[ __ ] hell I gotta go back to oh good
oh good
this [ __ ]
man [ __ ] these guys oh not that I'm
afraid of monsters or anything
oh oh oh say I'm hmm not in the mood to
deal with your bowl okay
no whoo ah yes
please give me that oh and it's got my
ammo still yes I still got my ammo
perfect whoa oh that thing not notice me
huh uh-huh yes more ammo and machine gun
ammo but I don't care about that
I like the shotgun better anyway all
right well wait
well then what was by the other guy let
me go see if there's something useful
around here if not yeah why was this
open so the AH so that you could spit in
my face all so that I could dumpster
dive well that's kind of defeat at the
point here just kill me there we go all
right let me dumpster dive for that
piece of health got it
get out get out get out dodge wait yeah
zigzag away on the best okay cool all
right I didn't think I'd make progress
as quickly I thought I would have gotten
stuck on that thing forever but
apparently I just zipped right by it
what's this I break any of these uh-huh
that's a negative
oh there's a battery on the ground and a
hammer a pistol mag I already had the
hammer those would be hard to see if you
I didn't have a eagle eyes like me let's
use a shotgun for a bit
well ah I see you come on
yeah upper um what the hell miss me
womp ah come on come on come at me bro
come at me come at me bro
ah what the hell screw that that's bull
dad
ah I see you fell other come on no come
on
ah Juke come on come on ah what the hell
die Jesus is this like a toughest one in
the world
[ __ ] I know I didn't hit it all the way
the first few times but still that
should have killed it whatever I should
have just ran past it whoa
yeah just screw them skip them J um
Madhu its Jane
oh okay hope that was another one it's
looks familiar it's looking a lot like
the city and cry of fear I guess they
would have used some of the same stuff
what the hell okay I'll go down I'll
play your game yoohoo rogue oh this just
goes back here well hello ha whoa whoa
what what the hell screw you [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell I mean my goodness no
respect come huh huh what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] or [ __ ] her e3 really it's either
this shotgun is weaker than the others
or they're getting stronger would that
do
okay Jesus that guy was like super fast
and super strong that shouldn't have
happened as a pile of [ __ ] pilot big
pop ah no come on
[ __ ] ah okay good I'm back here
anyway
take you right here where I should have
taken you there we go really oh these
guys messing with me
they screwing with me baby screwing with
me Mon Mon sir haha epic dodge yeah oh
wow
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that I
can't risk losing that much life
especially when one hit does that cuz
then the next hit takes me down to no
health
dad epic dodge I'm gonna give it aah
yeah ha ha
screw ha ha yeah
got it I win you all lose you there
under the stairs no and
what's in here hello broken doors huh
I'm not going in there you're talking
about destroyed elevator it's gonna send
me to my death
I see you [ __ ] ah yes one shot
perfect no lump Asst Whomper ooh see
that would have sent me to my death
probably probably would have let's see
what's up here huh battery okay they
haven't put me in any pitch-black places
you lately pills yes please ah damn it
god damn you damn you to hell
shoulda known it was a trap damn it ah
[ __ ] hell don't tell me I'm sorry
god damn it I can't take this damage ah
have a gun fine [ __ ] you [ __ ] your oh
god damn it you stupid son of it I such
a piece of [ __ ]
just put sat there so that I can
where is this going
well what good did that do Oh No
maybe some sort of cantilever something
or other I don't know exactly sure but
either way let's go back down into the
first elevator or what's through here
okay I needed that ah I get it I hit the
button then I get out ah
because it's a slight delay because I
need that elevator down there to go
across and do any of the uh let other
elevators somewhere else yes I do I need
the other other elevator mmm-hmm feed me
I've got something in my throat I need
the LA other elevator up so that it can
hop too or I can get through to the
other one okay oh wait a minute too far
huh maybe maybe I'm wrong I'm up your
own no I'm right there anything at the
bottom of the other nope okay yes this
is perfect yes I'm the best yeah okay
is there more head hands ah ah ah get
away get away
ah get away get away get away hello come
back I only need you to get away for a
little bit
damnit using too much ammo ah there we
go perfect taken care of anything in
there no of course not why would there
be ooh now that's a submachine gun womp
okay
alright on the back about 50 health
again okay but that gets rid of shoddy
but the shoddy have been proven useless
well not useless but I like it less wow
this looks weird God what kind of civil
engineer would put every other apartment
building at a 45-degree angle this is
bad planning bad layout bad aesthetics
battle all over come here bro
I could take you on ah missed yup oh
[ __ ] these are quick I better just I
better just screw it well not screw it
but bugger out whatever I'll kill this
one ah yeah okay and then I get down
from here to here perfect
yes beating the system well not really
cuz this is probably plan for this okay
and then I can jump from here to there
get this oh my god 77 health this is
amazing this is unbelievable the level
of skill
I must being I'm being affected by my
dead space to try my ax
ah [ __ ] never mind I my skill is gone
all gone my skill is terrible okay yeah
I already knew there was things on top
of the shipping containers so oh there
are things in the shipping containers oh
[ __ ] I gotta kill all these guys don't I
alibi oh boy whoa Nelly oh I can keep it
if I can bring them all over here then
that'll be better
ah okay so you all stay over here except
for that guy but I can take care of that
guy hello ah [ __ ] hell
got you one down you next come here come
here
yeah yeah do that word all walk that's
perfect
whoosh aah oh come on
we're dead [ __ ] did you come from screw
that that was I had 77 health then all
of a sudden boom gone and that was a
waste of bullets
ah so I can't believe I just said that I
was good at this game because I'm
obviously quite okay now did that one
just pop up because I touched the board
huh yep there you go okay cool
no not that way not how you troller oh
no that is the right way ha ha oh wait
no I could have gotten up here before
button
Curtin did own her junk it on her chunky
dog Kurt chunka donk donk a donk
now what is that why does it need to get
that box did I need to get that box for
any reason
okay hi guys bye guys actually that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I'll see you [ __ ] me I won't
see you [ __ ] me
uh-uh never mind I will see you in the
next part
bye bye